hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled operation moonshot rapid
translation of a sars cov2 lcms ms test
from research to routine use this
webinar is part of the clinical
diagnostics and research event and i'm
susie valdez of labyrinths and i will be
your moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab roots and sponsored by water
corporation
for more information about waters
corporation please go to waters.com
so let's get started before we begin i
want to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you first to
participate by communicating with other
attendees using our new live chat
feature during the presentation you can
find this live chat feature located at
the right of your screen
you can also participate by submitting
as many questions as you want during
this presentation to do so simply type
them into the ask a question box and
click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of this presentation
you will also notice that the speaker
has provided a survey located at the
right of the abstract
this survey will be available during
both live sessions and on the on-demand
period
provided
for you
now if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation just click on
that help desk button located at the
bottom of your screen with the
navigation bar is or from the lobby
finally as a reminder this presentation
is educational and offers free
continuing education credits click on
the continuing education credits link
located at the abstract window below the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain those credits i now
present today's speaker dr rachel
carling the scientific director at via
path guys and st thomas
nhsft
for a complete biography of our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top left of your screen dr karlin
welcome you may now begin your
presentation
thank you lance and thank you for
inviting me to talk today my day job is
actually metabolic biochemistry and
newborn screening so virtually all the
tests we do in my lab involve
chromatography or mass spec in some way
shape or form so when in the middle of a
pandemic last year the department of
health were looking for clinical labs
with mass spec experience we fitted the
bill nicely and we were invited to
participate in the moonshot project
this was a project set up in summer 2020
when there was concern over the uk's
capacity for covet testing and the aim
of the moonshot project was to identify
alternative
technologies to pcr for detecting covid
so my talk is kind of going to be in two
halves in the first half i'm going to
talk about the moonshot project itself
and then the second half will focus on
some of the developments which have
occurred since then so i think it's
probably just worth reminding everyone
what the definition of a moonshot is
because i think it helps to remind
ourselves of the context in which this
project originated and just how
ambitious it really was
so a moonshot is an ambitious
exploratory or groundbreaking project
undertaken without any expectation of
near-term profitability or benefit and
without a full investigation of the
potential risks and benefits
so the moonshot project was set up by
the department of health in summer last
year and it was a unique collaboration
between academia industry and the nhs
the academics were tasked with
developing an aspect method for sales
cop2 testing and the nhs clinical labs
were then tasked with operationalizing
the method undertaking a formal method
comparison and validating the method to
iso 15189 standards and of course the
entire process was supported by our
industry partners
so the academics involved with moonshop
were purchased of aaron from manchester
paul skip from southampton don jones
from leicester and kevin mills from
london and all of these people are
amazing scientists and they work
together to come up with this method in
a very short space of time
they've been given set performance
criteria by the department of health
that they had to meet so the method
needed to detect between two and five
target peptides from either the nuclear
captured or the spike protein
it also needed to have 95 sensitivity
and specificity at a ct of around 25 to
30 and it needed to be robust and lend
itself to scale up
so all in all i think you will probably
agree that the specification was in
keeping with the definition of a moon
shot
but these guys are really good and they
came up with version one of the method
by december last year and it quickly
became evident though that with just the
sp in place we didn't have the required
sensitivity
we were also struggling to get hold of
positive samples to play with and given
that we were in the middle of a global
pandemic that was really quite ironic
however they were undeterred and by
january this year they'd introduced cis
kappa into the workflow
so ciscapper stands for stable isotope
standard capture antipeptide antibody
and the ciscapper really boosted the
sensitivity of the method quite
significantly and so it was ready to be
translated into the clinical
laboratories so i'll just give you a
brief overview of the method that the
academic labs developed
so the swap was deactivated at the point
of collection by collecting the sample
into an ethanol buffer now this was
really quite an elegant solution because
neither none of the academic or clinical
labs involved in the moonshot process
had access to category 3 facilities to
deactivate the samples so this was quite
important
the method required both the swab and
the ethanol buffer it was collected in
to be processed so we referred to the
ethanol buffer as a swab juice and we
needed to process the swab as well
because the ethanol fixed about half of
the viral material onto the swab
so the method followed a fairly standard
peptide workflow the protein was
precipitated and denatured with rapid
yes prior to undergoing a triptych
digestion to release the constituent
peptides and there were three target
peptides in the method
ayn ade and dgi and these peptides were
isolated using ciscapper technology
prior to detection by mass spec so just
talk a little bit more about ciscapper
in case you're not familiar with how it
works
so as i said it stands for stabilized
type standard and capture by antipeptide
antibody and it's a really clever
technology
the antibodies against the target
peptides are coated onto magnetic
particles which can then be incubated
with a digested sample
and the antibodies capture the target
peptides and after the particles have
been washed the target peptides can be
eluted and injected into the mass spec
and basically the cis kappa step
replaced the spe in the original method
and really improved the sensitivity
and then what this slide is just trying
to illustrate is how the process
actually works in practice
so the brown solution that you can see
in plate 1 in the picture is the
magnetic particles once they've been
added to the digested swab samples
the plate is then incubated at room
temperature for an hour and then placed
onto the magnetic array which is shown
here in picture two
and the magnets sit in between any four
wells on the plate and they pull the
beads to one side and hopefully in
picture three you can just see the
pellet of beads that's formed at the
corner of each well and once this has
happened you can go in with a pet and
obviously you can use a multi-channel
prepare and you can remove
the solution
and then the process is repeated a
couple more times before the peptides
are eluted from the beads so as one of
the clinical labs involved in this
project i think it is fair to say that
in many respects the academic academic
labs have done all the hard work for us
however i think it's probably worth just
saying a little bit about the analytical
challenge that this project presented
for the clinical chemistry labs
so at the moment virtually all clinical
mass effect work in the uk is small
molecule work we offer quantitative
assays which we
hope are accurate precise and selective
and we measure the concentration of an
analyte in a fixed amount of biological
material be that plasma urine or a dry
bloodspot most of the analytes that we
measure are present at around 0.1 to 100
micromolar concentration and although
most lcms methods are limited somewhat
by the lack of automation and
pre-analytics they are typically
considered to be the gold standard
method of analysis so proteomics was an
entirely new field for us we normally
precipitate the protein and keep the
supernatant and all of a sudden we were
doing the reverse and to be honest it
did require a little bit of getting your
head around so we were measuring
peptides but because we were working
with swab samples we had no idea how
much biological material we had started
with so we couldn't report an actual
concentration all we could really do was
determine the amount of material that
we'd injected onto the column and this
again was an entirely unfamiliar concept
to me
and of course the concentration range
that we were trying to measure at
literally blew my mind
we were looking at concentrations that
were six to seven orders of magnitude
lower than anything i'd ever known a
triple quad do
but i think for me one of the best
things about this project was that in
december last year we got mass specs
with this kind of capability installed
into my lab at st thomas's and here they
are so these were my two shiny new water
zebo tqxss
um i named them obviously um and i call
them frank and leslie and this is after
frank pick and leslie green of london
underground fame
so frank was the chief executive of
london passenger transport board and
leslie was the architect who was
responsible for the characteristic
oxblood reds tube stations and the
really lovely platform tiling patterns
which some of you might be familiar with
but frank and leslie were creative
strategic and visionary
and i think that was really just like
the moonshot project was so it seemed
like a good name for them
so thanks to our industry partners we
had the kit and thanks to the academic
labs we had a method
so our job as clinical labs was then to
solve optimize the method to make it
work in the routine clinical environment
and do a massive comparison with pcr and
validate the method to iso 15189
standards so we took um a fairly
evidence-based approach to this and we
did make some minor tweaks to the method
but primarily we focused on identifying
a calibration strategy
introducing quality control
and working out how to determine whether
a result was positive or negative
and once we'd done this we did a fairly
straightforward method validation and
then the method comparison with pcr
samples
which of course pcr is considered to be
the gold standard method of analysis for
coping testing
um and it's probably also just worth
mentioning that the other thing we did
was to firmly badge the method as
qualitative and although from the ucas
perspective it would be classed as
semi-quantitative because we are
generating numerical results to assist
with the classification in my opinion
the method is essentially qualitative so
i'll just take you through the
highlights of the method validation now
so um we dropped the dji peptide from
the method quite early on because we
found that there were significant issues
with carryover and it also lacked the
sensitivity of the other two peptides
but as a learning point it is always
useful to include a number of target
peptides when you're starting to develop
a method so you can work out which ones
perform best as you go along so luckily
the other two peptides ayn and ade
performed well and we found that they
had acceptable sensitivity
and precision and negligible carryover
we also found that the method was
selective there was no cross-reactivity
from influenza a influenza b or rsb
and until the delta variant came along
the target peptides were unaffected by
the mutations so however the um the
delta variant did result in a mutation
on the ade peptide and this slide is
just trying to describe this visually
for you
so these um in highlighted in green here
you can see the three target peptides
that we've been looking at the dgi the
ayn and the ade but the delta variant
resulted in eight different point
mutations and these are highlighted in
the peptide sequence in red
and the d377y mutation
was um on the ade target peptide and
that's circled and what happened to it
was that the ade became aye in the delta
so this mutation reduced the affinity of
the ciscapper for the ade peptide or
should i say for the aye peptides but
luckily only by approximately 20 percent
so by adding in the mrms for aye into
the mass effect method we were still
able to detect delta variant which was a
real bonus so we did a method comparison
against the thermo fischer
tacpath pcr assay and we compared swabs
from 396 subjects which were collected
as part of the falcon study
and these samples were collected from
people in hospital by healthcare
professionals but also by people
screening themselves at home as part of
the population testing program
we had to exclude 35 samples due to
either poor sample quality or an
inconclusive pcr result which left us
with 361 in the final method comparison
and we found that the mass spec method
had a sensitivity of 92.4
and a specificity of 97 compared with
pcr
and that gave a positive predictive
value of 96.9 percent and cohen's kappa
um demonstrated that there was excellent
agreement between the methods which was
really good
um i think it's also worth pointing out
here that the pcr and mass spec results
were coming from different swab samples
so the efficacy of the swap sampling
process will also be impacting on the
comparison between the two
and to try to put that in a little bit
of context a comparison of just over 500
paired swab samples which were measured
both measured by pcr the same pcr method
but in different labs that gave an error
rate of three percent
um and because there is um a lot of
discussion and perhaps a lack of clarity
around what a ct value um above 32
actually means in terms of someone's
infection we did split out
those samples with ct of greater than 32
and just have a look at what that did to
the sensitivity and as you would expect
it did improve it significantly
as to whether or not that's an
acceptable thing to do i think i would
leave that to um our virologists to
comment on so i think in terms of the
original mask the moonshot project was
really successful
an lcms method had been developed very
quickly and translated into the clinical
lab where it's been validated and both
the analytical performance and the
comparison with pcr
were acceptable however
the method did also have some
limitations which meant it wasn't really
that suitable for the routine clinical
laboratory
i think for me the main one was the
bespoke sample collection tube so
although it was ingenious in its own way
it wasn't logistically feasible and in
fact it made access to patient samples
incredibly difficult
and the table shown here on the slide
just gives you an idea of just how many
samples were received in an incorrect
volume of ethanol which is a reflection
of the tubes being prepared manually and
not through a kind of commercial and
control process and also because both
the swab and the swab juice had to be
processed the method was really a
one-shot method and which obviously
isn't ideal in the routine lab because
you can never go back you just got one
chance to get it right
and again processing the swap without
automation was quite tricky and perhaps
more importantly there was a real risk
of cross-contamination from doing that
um and then on top of that the method
was incredibly labor-intensive and
time-consuming so the mass spec aspect
was really pretty fast but the rate
limiting step was the manual sample
preparation and which really did mean
that if you were doing this manually
without any automation you could really
only prep 20 samples in a day so i think
for me for the method to be suitable for
use in a routine clinical lab the first
thing that needed to change was a sample
type i mean the world and his wife were
collecting swaps for covid into btm and
we needed the method to work on btm we
also needed the process to be automated
partly for ease and simplicity but also
so the throughput was increased and i
think ideally we needed a
post-analytical data processing solution
because the existing process
required review of the numerical data
and visual inspection quite careful
visual inspection of every single
chromatogram so i think really this is
where our industry partners came into
their own so my lab had been partnered
with waters and we've been having some
ongoing discussions about how the method
might work with btm samples but progress
in actually doing something was slow
partly because of the difficulty of
getting hold of reagents so the cis
kappa um was like gold dust in january
february time this year
but also getting hold of positive
samples was quite difficult and this did
slow down our progress but walters came
up with a reagent kit which was designed
to work with btm samples which solved
two of our problems straight away and
then they also loaned us a benchtop
robot the andrews alliance to help with
sample preparation and this had such a
positive impact we also sent um our swap
data to them and hans vittez um was busy
working has been busy working on an
algorithm to try and classify the
samples and i was really pleased a
couple of months ago when he came back
and had independently verified the
classifications that we've done manually
during the validation here's a nice
picture of the um the saskov2 reagent
kit from waters
so the kit method is really similar to
the ethanol-based method i've just been
describing to you but it does have some
important differences
so this kit has three target peptides
the ayn and the ade that we described
previously but it also has another
peptide npa which is also derived from
the nuclear capsid protein
all the reagents including the ciscapper
are provided in the kit
um the lc method is a little bit shorter
it's two minutes and that's because the
dji peptide is no longer included
and most importantly for me the method
is intended to be used with a swab
collected into vtm
so as i'm sure you can imagine i was
really keen to get my hands on some kits
and try and do some validation work so
this meant i needed to find some patient
samples
and luckily with the help of some
colleagues in the emergency department i
was able to obtain ethics to collect
samples at st thomas's
so our inclusion criteria was very
straightforward any adult presenting to
the emergency department between june
and august this year with symptoms of
consistent with covid and who consented
to provide us with a second swab
so that swab sample was sent to our
virology department and they took
responsibility for anonymizing the
samples deactivating them and preparing
two aliquots they kept one electron for
pcr um and then they sent one aliquot to
us for mass spec so of course a major
benefit of this comparison um was that
the pcr would have been done on the
exact same sample as the mass effect so
that would just rule out any of those
potential differences due to the
efficacy of the sampling process and by
the beginning of september we had just
over 300 samples to validate the kit on
so obviously again we did a method
comparison with pcr
this time we use the oz diagnostics
method and that's a two-step pcr essay
and just to confuse things a little bit
this assay didn't report in ct values it
used the takeoff value so a really
strong positive will amplify
sufficiently in the first step of the
process and if that's immediately
detectable in the second step so that
the takeoff value would effectively then
be zero um so we used the andrews
alliance for the um for the sample prep
so this is the top robot which waters
lent us um it's a user programmable
robot and it can do a variety of things
so it can pipette it can mix and it can
shake and it also has a magnetic array
on it so it can do the cisco steps too
and basically the andrews did all the
hard work for us we just had to plate
out the etm samples and then transfer
the plate onto the andrews and let it do
the rest and i've just got a short clip
which i'll just see if i can play for
you very quickly now
so it's just the andrew's done cutting
out some of the cisco
um so this slide is just an attempt to
illustrate to you what a difference the
robot made
so the preparation of the ethanol
samples was entirely manual and the rate
limiting step here was really the number
of cisco washes because the three
syscapper wash sets have to be completed
within 15 minutes and that just
effectively limited the number of
samples that you could process in one go
and we found with the manual process
that was about 24.
the process was also incredibly time
consuming and it took seven hours and
five hours of that was actually touch
time
so by using the andrews um to prepare
the ethanol samples it meant that we
could do 48 samples in one go again the
rate limiting step was being able to
complete three cisco wash steps in 15
minutes and even the andrews could only
do this for 48 samples at a time
so that was the rate limiting step it
did speed the process up though so the
total time to prep 48 samples was five
and a quarter hours and with a contact
time of about two and a quarter hours
however
waters were able to show that the um
btm method only required two wash steps
of the cyst capper so that meant that
the andrews could prep 96 samples in a
time which was a real game changer
so the total time was still about five
and a quarter hours but the contact time
was reduced to one hour 30 minutes and
one hour of that was um me plating out
the samples and ready to go onto the
andrews so i'm just going to give walk
you through the highlights of the um the
validation that we did with the waters
kick now so obviously we looked at
linearity
um and this slide shows the calibration
curves for each peptide so these
calibrations are based on synthetic
peptides not on encap
and the peptides have been taken through
the sample preparation process even
though technically they didn't need to
be just for completeness and to ensure
that they were i guess matrix matched we
did um have to be honest going forward i
don't think there's any merit in doing
this and i think i in future i would
just run them as offline cows um and it
was also probably worth just clarifying
that the aye peptide has been calibrated
against the ade so the table here
summarizes the r squared values and the
back calculated concentrations for
calibrations over five days and i think
you can
i hope you can see that the ayn and ade
performed quite well but the npa a
little bit less so and we found that the
mpa wasn't particularly stable
and it was also considerably less
sensitive than the other two peptides so
calcu for npa shown here is actually at
concentration 10 times higher
than that of the other two peptides um
in terms of imprecision we made some um
three pools qc samples um
that were made up from patient swabs
collected into btm so we had a negative
pool a low positive pool and high
positive cool
unfortunately because of issues with
access to samples we were only able to
obtain one qc for ade and that was a
weak positive pool
um we found the assay was reasonably
precise the interbat imprecision was
around 10 in the high pool and around 20
in the low positive pool and so
obviously if you're used to quantitative
essays that perhaps doesn't sound like
brilliant performance but i just think
bearing in mind the concentrations that
we're um looking at here and the fact
that this is really a qualitative assay
i think that's reasonable performance
and i think we can be confident in that
we also found that the assay was
selective um we analyzed 18 patient
samples which were positive for one of
the four other seasonal corona viruses
and found no cross-reactivity with um
covid
so that was good and we also looked at
spike's recombinant end cap which with
increasing concentrations of influenza a
influenza b and rsv and again there was
no cross reactivity at all so i'm just
going to show you some example
chromatograms so you have
an idea of the kind of data that we were
getting from this method
so these are the um extracted ion
current chromatograms from a negative
sample
um each peptide has a quantifier and at
least one qualifier iron and of course
there's a stabilized text standard
included as well so on the top here
we've got a y e x ay n sorry in the
middle we've got ade and aye
and npa's at the bottom and for each
peptide you can see here just glancing
at it that only the stable isotopes are
present so this was a true negative
the next one we've got an example of is
a true positive result so again ayn is
at the top
a d e and a y e are in the middle and
mpa is at the bottom
and this time you can see that in
addition to the stable isotope ayn and
both its qualifier ions are present
aye and it's qualified iron are present
and at the bottom you can see that we've
got the mpa and both its qualifier ions
so this is a bond or positive and
obviously it's also a delta variant so
this next slide is just summarizing the
concentration of the aym peptide for
samples that were pcr negative and pcr
positive um the pcr-positive samples
have been split into those with a
takeoff value
of greater than 20 so in other words the
low positives and those with a takeoff
value of less than 20 which obviously
are the um the more straightforward
positives
and what this slide is really showing
you that there is no really clear
discrimination between the um a positive
and a negative in terms of absolute
concentration and again this is the same
um the same information but for the
other two peptides aye and mpa and again
you can see that there isn't absolute
discrimination between a positive and a
negative they've also been um
looking at the data to see if we can
extract any other information out of it
so had to look at whether the how the
ayn
correlates with the take-off value and
you can see that there's broad
correlation as you would expect
but not particularly good correlation i
think the one that correlates the best
is actually aye it's got an r squared
value of 0.779 though so it's not really
brilliant
also been looking at ratios um this box
whisker plot just shows um the ratio of
the aui and the other two peptides and
we were looking in case it added some
discriminatory value but again you can
see for both peptides the range is
actually quite large so we'll continue
to go through the data and see if we can
um draw anything else out from it and
obviously i think it's probably worth
mentioning that at some point in the
next couple of weeks i'll be sending
all this data on to waters as well to
see if hands can do anything um more
sophisticated with it in terms of um
the sensitivity and specificity um this
is probably the most interesting bit
of the 325 swabs we managed to collect
from the symptoms emergency department
we had to exclude 10 because there was
either insufficient sample volume
or there was an inconclusive pcr result
and that left 315 in the final
comparison and we found that the mass
spec method had a sensitivity of 75
and a specificity of 100 compared with
pcr
again cohen's kappa um was greater than
0.83
which is consistent with excellent
agreement between the methods
we also looked at the um those samples
were the takeoff
um of less than 20
as a separate group and you can see that
that increased the sensitivities um
quite significantly to 92.9 percent so i
think um in conclusion the waters
sasquatch ii kit has been validated on
vtm patient samples it's got acceptable
analytical performance and we also found
the method to be very specific it's not
going to give false positive which is a
definite advantage and i think in terms
of sensitivity um it performs well at
the lower take-off values and although
the higher take-off values its
performance isn't as great it's not
actually um it's it's comparable to
other antigen tests that are available
and used routinely such as the rosh
alexis assay
so
i think um
what we've also shown is that if the
process is automated it could be
suitable for a routine clinical
environment
but i think for me um
what risk is really doing is kind of
demonstrating the art of the possible
um
i think the moonshot project has
demonstrated what can be achieved and
just how quickly if industry academia
and the nhs work together in partnership
and i think that's really important i
think it's also highlighted the benefits
of investing in high-end kit in clinical
laboratories
um but again for me i think the real
take-home message is that clinical labs
can do peptide analysis we've got the
kit and we've got a workflow
and for me that means we have a whole
new set of biomarkers available to us
and the question really is just which
one we want to start with
so obviously moonshot has been a massive
collaborative project
and there are loads of people that have
been involved and need to be
acknowledged um i obviously haven't
captured them all on this slide but i
very much hope i've got the um the key
players
so there's the rest of my team in
biopath
in particular kate john and kaylee davis
who have been helping on the lab side
and penny cliff who is my contact and um
very friendly virologist
and then kevin mills and his team from
the institute of child health they were
our partner p1 laboratory um and they
were fabulous to work with and obviously
then there's the team from waters
and then those people that were working
directly at the department of health
i'll stop there and if anybody would
like to ask any questions i'll be more
than happy to try to answer them thank
you
so there was a question about the
take-home messages in terms of the
peptide assays and i think for us it was
the need to include multiple target
peptides
during the validation process and also
particularly for the kovitch we didn't
have a marker of swab integrity in there
which was unfortunate because our
results would perhaps have been a little
bit more easy to interpret but because
we were using assist kappa that actually
prevented us from going back and adding
in um a potential marker in real time so
i think that's something to bear in mind
so there is massive advantages of the
cisco in terms of sensitivity um but it
does mean you can't just add additional
things into your assay which um which is
fine but i think the lead time forces
kappa to produce new antibodies is
between six and nine months so it's just
something to bear in mind
i'm just going to have a look and see if
there's been any more questions
notes there's just um
one other question that i've got in the
chat
um about what we what else we learned
during the essay so we're actually in
the process of doing a formal lessons
learned um review which is something
we're quite keen on in england
sorry about the background noise um
so we've just contacted everyone who's
involved in moonshot um with a
questionnaire um asking their thoughts
on what went well how we can improve
things in the future so that if we ever
do do another collaborative project in
this way we will be able to focus in on
what worked well and avoid some of the
areas where we perhaps made mistakes and
which i think is important because there
were so many people involved it was
difficult to keep track of where
everybody was at some point in time
i'm just checking the chat i don't think
there's any more questions
so i guess i'll hand back
to aaron
thank you dr carling for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of our
webinar and if you have any questions
you want to ask please do so now just
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen
so let's get started it looks like we
already have some great questions coming
in
our first question
what did you learn from the moonshot
project
um that's a good question i learned a
lot i think
i learned about peptide analysis which
um i found really useful and quite
excited about
and i believe that in the states you do
a lot more with peptides already in the
routine clinical laboratory than we do
so i think that that's an area that we
would like to really expand not
necessarily expand into but start
looking at in more detail and i'd
actually be keen to hear from anyone
who's got more experience than we do
with peptide analysis but i think also
learnt a lot about working as part of a
team because there was obviously quite a
lot of people involved in moonshot
everybody had um an individual role but
we also needed to work together and on
top of that we were kind of
geographically dispersed across
the whole of the uk so that was quite
challenging so yeah it was definitely a
steep learning curve but it was a very
enjoyable experience
thank you so much and dr crawling will
the method be able to detect the new
variants
um so that's a very good question so
obviously um it depends on what the new
variant is so until the delta variant
came along the method wasn't affected by
any of the mutations that we were aware
of um so for example the temperature the
kent mutate the kent variant and the
california the south african and
brazilian i think all of those mutations
were predominantly on the spike protein
so they didn't affect our encap peptides
so in the event that we get a variant
like the delta variant which does affect
the encap peptide the first question is
whether it affects one of our target
peptides
and then as with the delta variant um
it's about whereabouts from the target
peptide it is and how that affects the
binding to the ciscapper so we were
lucky really with delta in the sense
that although it did affect the ay ade
peptide um the ciscapper was owned the
affinity was only decreased by about 20
so we still captured the peptide
successfully and i guess that's the
beauty of mass spec because just by
updating our mrms to reflect the change
in the peptide we were able to still
detect the delta variant and because
obviously we have got three peptides in
the method um i guess it would be not
impossible but unfortunate if a mutation
came a variant came along which had
mutations which affected all three
peptides at the same time so i guess
worst case scenario you may lose one but
hopefully the presence of the other two
still allow you to detect the covid
thank you so much and i want to thank
our audience for these great questions
our next question why did you compare to
the off diagnostics method when
validating the kit and not the
attack
asset
yeah so um that was the way the project
works so in the first part of the
project as part of the moon shot and we
we'd already got an agreement to do the
um comparison with the crick laboratory
um in london and they were using the
tacpath assay so when we went on to
validate the waters kit
that was just done in my center which is
um symptoms of hospital in london so we
had to validate the pcr essay and we had
to validate against our own pcr essay
and that our biology department were
using our diagnostics um i was a bit
perturbed at first because
the old diagnostics assay measures
things in terms of takeoff value not ct
so that took a little bit of getting our
head around but i think in terms of the
practicalities um and the um the
validity of the validation um it doesn't
really make any difference because you
can't compare but my understanding is
anyway that you can't necessarily
compare the ct values from one pcr assay
to another anyway um so yeah it's just
the way that things worked out for us
thank you so much and we have one more
question coming in can you explain the
criteria used to classify results as
either positive or negative
yes so so this was um
this was probably one of the most
interesting aspects of the project
because one of our jobs as the p2
laboratory was to work out exactly how
to do that so we were measuring the
three target peptides and for each
peptide we had a quantifier iron and two
qualifier ions so we would look
individually just visually at each
peptide to check that the quantifier and
the qualifiers were there and if they
were we would class that as positive for
that individual peptide but then we
would look collectively at the three
peptides and we would want to have two
out of the three present before we would
um classify the sample as positive
and then we were lucky because um as i
mentioned earlier we were able to send
the data um on to
hans vistas at water who looked at it
retrospectively
and used much more uh sophisticated
techniques than me sat in front of the
mass spec looking at the screen and he
actually came back and validated what we
found um using sort of um more
sophisticated algorithms so yeah so that
was good and again for me that was one
of the learning points of the project
because certainly in the uk the way we
process our data post analytically is
often quite basic and i think that
there's um there's things that we can
take forward and learn here
and apply to some of our other assays my
um
day job is metabolic biochemistry so i'd
like to see how this could look with
atop antenes and amino acids things like
that as well
dr carlene this has been a pleasure
thank you for your presentation today do
you have any closing remarks you'd like
to provide for our audience before we go
um no just thank you very much for
inviting me to speak to you today i hope
you found the talk interesting and if
anybody would does have experience of
peptides analysis in the clinical
laboratory i'd really like to hear from
you and hear about how you've got on and
what analytes you've been measuring
that'd be really useful for me
well thank you again dr carling and
thank you for your time and for your
important research and before we go i
want to thank our audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions i'd also like to thank our
sponsor waters corporation for
sponsoring today's webinar questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by our speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration and this webcast
can be viewed on demand for two years
until november 2023 laboratory alert via
email when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time take
care everyone stay healthy bye